What do you think?
Would this man make a good doctor?
What about him?
Would you trust him with your surgery?
Most people would probably want to get treated
by one, rather than the other.
And most people are likely to be wrong about
that.
When you look at the sun, you sometimes see
it clearly.
But sometimes you’ll see it shining way
bigger than its actual shape.
That circle of light that makes it look bigger
is called a halo.
The halo effect also happens when a person,
product, or company shines like the sun.
Then we don’t see them clearly and associate
all sorts of unrelated qualities to them.
The halo effect was first identified in 1907
by the American psychologist Frederick Wells
and was then studied by the psychologist Edward
Thorndike, who asked flight commanders to
evaluate their officers in various distinct
aspects such as physical appearance, intelligence,
and leadership.
Examining the results, Thorndike found that
the officers that got high scores for their
psychical qualities, also got rated high on
intelligence and leadership skills - a correlation
that seemed wrong.
It appears that the commanders were unable
to evaluate specific traits independently
of others.
They thought of their officers in broad terms;
either "good" or "bad", and allowed this general
feeling to influence the specific qualities
they attributed to them.
Some officers profited from their halo.
Others were put at a disadvantage by what
is called the horn effect.
The halo effect also explains why some teachers
give better looking students higher grades
One study looked at the grades of 4,500 pupils,
who were sorted by volunteers into three groups:
below-average, average, and above-average
looking.
Did the better looking people get better grades?
The researchers then compared students' grades
between classes taken in traditional classrooms
with those taken online where there was little
to no face-to-face interaction.
The researchers later found evidence that
students who were rated as good looking, earned
significantly lower grades in online courses
compared to traditional classrooms where they
got help from their halo.
Since the physical attributes of good looking
people seem to naturally make them also appear
intelligent, strong, and trustworthy, here
is one good rule of thumb.
If you have an accident and you have to choose
between two equally qualified doctors, ignore
their halo and choose the less handsome one.
He might have worked twice as hard to gain
the same reputation and is likely better at
his job.
What do you think?
Do you think it is possible to avoid the halo
effect at work, in school or in public life?
And what about other credentials that may
signal success?
Please share your thoughts and ideas in the
comments below.
This and all other Sprouts' videos are licensed
under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses
or
to start projects - and today, thousands already
do!
To learn how it works and download this video
without Ads or background music, checkout
our website or read the description below.
If you want to support our mission and help
change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.